all right so now we're going to talk
about propellers now there's pretty much
two major types of propellers the one
these little two fifties I actually kind
of like because the motors the shaft on
the motor is actually threaded on a lot
of the more powerful motors it's not
threaded and you don't have the ability
to have these quick attached ones but
with those smaller ones for some reason
that seems more popular to have the
quick attach so you've got two different
types of propellers like this is one
type where literally it's like through
and through right you could go right
through and then you've got this this
propeller which I'd has a little cap on
it but in the inside whoops hello there
we go on the inside it's threaded and so
it makes putting them on the actual
quadcopter like really fast and taking
them off really fast
the downside is propellers especially
cheap propellers like these come and
they're way off balance and so what I'm
going to talk about briefly is balancing
we're not I'm not going to be using
these carbon-fiber ones but this is just
evidence of nice quality propellers so
what this is is this is a propeller
balancer and the way that it works is
you basically screw the propeller in and
you clamp it between like these two
things here and this is like a magnet
right so it's just like a really good
bearing almost and you will balance the
propeller on here and the goal is to put
it on a level surface right and the
propeller basically stay totally level
not one side coming bang down onto the
surface as you can see this propeller is
actually really well balanced I've never
received a propeller that was balanced
I've always had to apply something to
balance them so actually this is pretty
good proof of why you want nice
propellers but at the same time I don't
really have too much problem with these
little cheap ones obviously you really
can't balance these I mean you there's a
few things you you could possibly do
like you could there's a few things you
do but anyway if you do balance a
propeller all you do is you add like
little pieces of tape to the bottom side
of the propeller and that will add more
weight obviously tiny pieces of weight
will do the trick but honestly on my
larger quad I balanced all the
propellers just because I can obviously
I've never can't balance these
propellers and if I'm being honest there
is really I don't notice the difference
maybe if you were like a super good
pilot or something but I get plenty
stable flight and I've never had to
balance a propeller the only thing that
you have to do is you know you just trim
on your controller fairly frequently
right so anyways what we're going to do
is I'm going to take these off obviously
it's like if you use the carbon carbon
propellers take note this is white like
with these propellers it's impossible to
make the mistake of putting the wrong
propeller on because literally the
threading just won't work but on the
larger quads with the shaft it's not
even threaded or anything they just
slide on that's that was my that's my
first learning experience but anyway so
make sure you're using the right
propeller like usually it'll say like
which way is supposed to spin but you
can also look at a propeller and you can
tell it's it's shaped down this way so
in order for there to be thrust down
this propeller must spin clockwise so
this would actually be for a black one
but I'm just going to show you and in
fact maybe this one's different right
this one's been counterclockwise so this
would be the correct one for this motor
and then so you would put this on and
then you would just screw this on over
it right that would be all you would do
but I'm going to use these these other
ones also I like using the different
colored propellers simply because it's
easier to see the orientation of the
quad another really great thing to do is
to put like LED lights on there and then
that's even better than the colored
props but anyway maybe with the
Raspberry Pi we'll add some of that but
but for now let's just get this thing
taken off so I'm gonna put on the
propellers and then when I go to my
garage and we're at least gonna test it
slightly and then if things go well
congratulations and if things go poorly
we'll you know debug
so on the first flight I like to give
enough throttle to be able to test the
motions like forwards backwards in side
to side and this will at least tell you
if your controllers directions are about
right but of course due to the
quadcopter quite literally dragging
against the ground and air pressure
created from being so close to the
ground you won't know too much more
until you take off but you wanna make
sure these four controls are correct
despite that you still might have some
minor problems
all right so that was a lot of fun a
couple couple issues right out of the
gate actually the first thing was I
noticed probably the most important
thing actually was that I noticed the
wires coming from the battery to the
actual quad here you know basically as
you're putting the thing together you're
kind of being mindful of the wires the
whole time and usually what I do is I'll
put a propeller on and I'll spin the
propeller around and just see is there
anything in the vicinity and I'll move
the wires and just try to hit the
propeller and if you can make the wire
hit the propeller eventually it'll hit
the propeller so you want to make sure
that never happens but I had never done
that with the battery plugged in and as
you can see this little adapter thing
it's just a problem I have to work on
this so I'll probably spin this bottom
plate around and change the orientation
of the plug coming out but anyway hadn't
checked for that and then when I was in
my garage I kind of it caught my eye and
I was like oh that's a problem so I took
a zip tie and actually zip tied it over
here at least just for testing purposes
but I'll end up actually having to take
this apart down here and probably
spinning the actual power distribution
board around but anyway so I'll be doing
that but then the other thing that was a
problem was for some reason on my board
the motor layout got reset not it was
just reset to that first option again
not an X copter so yeah that's why the
sensors just went crazy I guess huh
so that kind of sucked but at least all
I know that happen is we broke a
propeller and I was more than prepared
I've got tons of these things so anyway
not a big deal but anyway so that's out
if you have questions comments is you're
quite not working for whatever reason
I've put together like yeah I'm not a
pro or anything but I put together five
of these and actually if anything I'm an
idiot and I've made a lot of mistakes
putting them together so chances are if
you having a problem with something I've
come across that problem so feel free to
ask below and I'll do my best to help
you otherwise what's coming up is as you
can see I've actually already got the
Raspberry Pi on there the Grove PI is on
there
I wanted to put those on there
immediately just because that way I can
hold it I can hold the quad like this
and see if things are balanced or not
and so I wanted to put everything on
there at once because I wanted to make
sure I could place everything in such a
way that center of gravity was where it
needed to be so anyway that's already on
there we're ready to start slapping on a
bunch of sensors and all that there will
at least be adding a distance sensor and
a camera
I've got there's other sensors I really
want like accelerometer and altimeter
and stuff like that but it's gonna be
kind of difficult I'm having a hard time
getting my hands on these sensors they
seem to be pretty hard to get there are
almost always out of stock well
something's different anyway so before
you go flying your quad off into the
sunset there's a few things you need to
think of before you head out the door so
you need to consider the rules of laws
and all that in the area that you live
so for example I live in the United
States of America and then more micro I
live in the state of Texas so just for
some examples here in the United States
of America if you fly around a drone
outside you need to have that drone
registered with the FAA yes this is a
drone so some other things this might be
is an aircraft it might be a
surveillance device and it could even be
a deadly weapon
so be very careful so anyways in the
United States of America if you want to
fly your drone outside anywhere
including your own backyard you have to
register with the FAA you can fly around
in your garage without registering with
the FAA so that's one then we go to the
more micro level in the great state of
Texas there is no such thing as public
land so a lot of states in the Union
have what's known as public land where
it's almost like this nice communal land
that everybody shares and can do all
kinds of fun stuff on it well in Texas
no all land is private land it just so
happens that Texas has other laws
regarding drones and one of those laws
would be you cannot surveil somebody or
record somebody with your drone so you
can't record a private individual on
private property with your drone if you
do and you disperse that media ie you
just put it you got a new
new drone you put a camera on there and
he showed some people you you flew
around the drone you saw some cool stuff
and then you uploaded it to YouTube well
guess what if you capture a private
individual on private property
you can be fined a lot of money it's
like I swear it's like ten ten thousand
dollars per second of footage it's
absurd so keep that in mind and imagine
how difficult it is to fly a drone
around with a camera on it and not
capture a private individual and private
property because all property is private
so seriously so then you might be
thinking ah I will just take my drone to
a park fly it around on the park wall on
there little giant because guess what
parks are not public land again those
are owned by the federal government most
likely more specifically the US Army
Corps of Engineers so you think I'm
gonna be safe I'm gonna go fly it around
in the park and keep it away from people
and all this kind of stuff maybe a
football field or soccer field nobody's
on it too bad you are on private
property government property you fly it
around US Army Corps of Engineers
personnel will come and greet you not
that I know from experience and will
tell you you cannot fly aircraft on
their land well I don't think this is an
aircraft it is you know does the start
of a definition of what is not a drone
and what is an aircraft is fifty five
pounds but I digress I'm not about to
argue with the Army Corps of engineer
person why I'm on their land it's not
even your land so no matter what if they
ask you to leave you have to leave
otherwise guess what's another law
violation which is trespassing so it can
be difficult so if you live in a state
like Texas that is not so drone friendly
as some of the other states they're the
first place you should go is the AMA
it's Academy of model aeronautics and
you'll want it you need to be a member
with them it's like I think $80 a year
or something like that and then you can
go to any AMA location you might have to
pay a membership fee at that location
but you can go to any AMA location and
subsequently you can be a member and fly
around so around me there's a place
that's only like 10 15 minutes away it's
got a 500 foot by 50 foot concrete
runway it's a really badass place to fly
like that
this is the best place to fly so it's
not so bad
if you do have horrible laws in your
area because chances are somebody has
done something and if not well guess
what that plot of land is leased from
who you guessed it US Army Corps of
Engineers it's like I forget how many
acres it's a lot of acres I want to say
it's like I can't remember how many
acres I'll get the number wrong but it's
a huge plot of land and it's leased from
the US Army Corps of Engineers for I
think like fourteen hundred dollars a
year so yeah not that much money you can
get a group of people together and you
can you can figure it out okay so
anyways long story short pay attention
to the rules and laws in your area you
might see this as a fun toy but the law
might not so so just keep that in mind
don't be stupid and you probably won't
find yourself in trouble so anyways that
concludes the first section of the
series go out and fly a little drone
around they're so much fun to fly
they're super maneuverable and they're
really fast actually I'm surprised how
fast these things can get up to like 40
miles an hour
or even faster if you put some really
nice stuff on there and make it nice and
lightweight and then they turn on a dime
it's crazy
so anyways go out and have some fun be
legal be safe and till next